la parole à Monsieur Jean-François
Humber pour le groupe
UMP monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur Michel Sapin monsieur le
ministre qui peut encore croire à la
promesse réaffirmé cette semaine par
François Hollande d'inverser la courbe
du chômage d'ici à la fin de l'année
personne nous le verrons bien ce soir
d'ailleurs 68 % des Français sont
inquièt de leur avenir ils peuvent
l'être avec un pouvoir d'achat en baisse
de 0,8 % au 4e trimestre de 2012 et de
0,4 % sur l'année 2012 selon
l'INC premier recul depuis
1984 principalement en raison de
ponction sociales et fiscales inégalés
ce sont les économistes qui le disent la
France souffre les Français souffrent
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
l'appel à la mobilisation générale pour
l'emploi du Premier ministre lancé il y
a peu
quand plus de 260000 chômeurs
supplémentaires ont été enregistrés en 9
mois soit un/ers environ de la hausse
enregistrée sur les 5 années précédentes
cet appel prend des allures
pathétiques c'était il y a 9 mois qu'il
fallait agir comme le président Hollande
s'y était engagé durant sa campagne au
lieu de cela vous avez multiplier les
réformes dites sociétales à l'écoute de
minorités proposer des réformes de
enance plus tactique qu'autre chose ce
ne sont pas 150000 emplois d'avenir
concrétisés jusqu'à présent et le
contrat de génération qui peuvent
constituer une politique face au fléau
du chômage bien plus vous avez envoyé
des signaux très concret de défiance
envers les entreprises dès le départ
provoquer un véritable choc fiscal alors
que c'est là dans les entreprises que se
crée la richesse de demain c'est d'elle
que viendra la croissance
comment l'espérer d'ailleurs cette
croissance quand un excès de norme rend
les entreprises françaises toujours plus
vulnérables dans le jeu de la
concurrence mondial certainement pas les
mesures du plan compétitivité emploi
permettez-moi une véritable usine à gaz
monsieur le ministre quand allez-vous
conduire une réelle politique de
l'emploi quand ce gouvernement va-t-il
enfin mettre de la cohérence dans sa
politique quand allez-vous arrêter de
dresser les Français les uns contre les
autres que comptez-vous faire pour
redonner de la confiance à PS et en ce
pays merci merci Monsieur Michel Sapin
ministre du
Travail merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Mesdames Messieurs les
sénatrices sénateurs merci monsieur le
sénateur pour cette question pleine
d'ambition sur le retour de la confiance
la confiance qui a disparu depuis de si
nombreuses années dans ce pays je me
souviens de quelqu'un vous trouverez le
nom qui disait à peine élu je vais aller
chercher la croissance avec les
dents quelle a été la croissance au
cours des 5 dernières années zéro zéro
croissance en 5 ans pas étonnant
qu'alors le nombre des chômeurs pendant
les mêmes 5 années est augmenté de plus
de 1 million je comprends totalement
c'est parfaitement dans votre rôle d'élu
parfaitement dans votre rôle d'élu et
vous le dites avec une modération dont
votre voisin immédiat devrait à
l'instant pouvoir s'inspirer il est tout
à fait dans votre rôle d'élu de poser
des questions sur ce sur le ch
l' mais faites-le s'il vous plaît vous
qui avez été responsable de grandes
collectivités territorial comme d'autres
ici faites-le avec la modestie de ceux
qui n'ont pas réussi qui n'ont pas
réussi qui ont échoué et qui à partir de
là sont parfaitement légitimes pour
donner des conseils mais doivent le
faire avec la retenue qui convient dans
ces cas-là monsieur le sénateur quel est
le sens quelle est la cohérence c'est
l'action ce sont des outils vous pouvez
vouloir tourner en dérision tel outil
les emplois d'avenir
150000 demandez-lui de s'inspirer de
votre modération à votre voisin je pense
que le Sénat tout entier en sera honoré
donc monsieur le sénateur 150000 emplois
d'avenir ils vont être mis en œuvre
100000 d'ici la fin de cette année les
collectivités territorial y compris de
votre département du dou de votre région
vont faire en sorte qu'il y ait des
emplois venir c'est autant de solutions
concrètes pour des jeunes qui
aujourd'hui n'ont aucune possibilité
d'emploi et n'ont aucune possibilité de
formation c'est concret c'est simple
mais il faut le mettre en uvre il faut
se mobiliser les uns et les autres vous
disiez à juste titre monsieur le
sénateur
réunissons-nous dans cette bataille pour
l'emploi agissons tous ensemble même si
ici il a pu y avoir des débats assez
normal en démocratie pour ou contre tel
outil mais les emplois d'avenir c'est
utile agissons ensemble le contrat de
génération vous n demandez des comptes
c'est normal de la part de la la
représentation national de demander des
comptes le contrat de génération il est
en application depuis lundi dernier
demandons des comptes mais il y en a
déjà qui sont signé et ça ça marche vous
le savez les employeurs les entreprises
les PME les PMI les artisans et les
commerçants de votre région ils sont en
train de s'emparer de ce très bel outil
extrêmement efficace pour les jeunes
comme pour les plus anciens oui monsieur
le sénateur réunissons-nous autour de
cette bataille qui est de l'intérêt de
la France et de chacun des Français la
lutte contre le chômage et nous
atteindrons ainsi ensemble l'objectif
que nousous sommes fixés inverser enfin
la courbe du chômage merci Monsieur
Pierre Bernard Rand pour la Réunion
administrative des sénateurs ne figurant
sur la liste d'aucun
groupe monsieur le président